it's three in the morning we're at
almost 4000 meters elevation climbers
are getting ready to leave the Alpine
mountain hut to attempt the ascent up
Mont Blanc today there are about 100
climbers from all over the world Naomi
and Andrew are from Australia they also
geared up to make the five hour climb
why not it's the tallest mountain in
Europe it's a easy mountain for someone
to do by themselves without a guide
non-technical a one more bye bye Naomi
ok ready let's do it Andrew and Naomi
have a 1000 meter climb ahead of them
they took a five day climbing course in
Peru and they think that will be enough
to master monk long but many
underestimate the difficulty of the
climb it's extremely arduous requiring
the strength and conditioning of a
marathon runner then there's also sudden
storms and bad weather avalanches and
crevices in the glacier to contend with
over the past 10 years more than 200
people have died in the Mont Blanc
mountain range meanwhile down in the
valley of Sasha ave it's last call in
the pubs the tourists enjoy living it up
but the mayor here is in no mood to
celebrate too many people lose their
lives on Mont Blanc confirm vodka a
Russian woman was left up there by her
fellow climbers because she couldn't
make it back down by the time the rescue
crew reached her she was dead you ganna
don't be so coy things like this
shouldn't happen yuppers i said to show
this up
there's little talk of tragedies in
nearby shamani bad news is bad for
business the sporting equipment shops
hotels and pubs rely on the throngs of
tourists to survive they're here for
Mont Blanc even if they don't plan to
climate Oh machine it's a wonderful view
it's the rooftop of Europe I've been up
there four times and it wasn't all that
long ago what good for maybe a porno
don't listen but do you want to go up to
the top and do what now you're climbing
nice King mm-hmm she's scary on this
crisp morning no tourists will make it
up to the top it's far too dangerous
with wind gusts of more than 80
kilometres an hour and temperatures of
minus 25 degrees Celsius Naomi and
Andrew also stopped at the last Alpine
hut before the peak naomi is chilled to
the bone but they still don't want to
give up we really want to make the seven
waiting up here at a height of four
thousand four hundred meters can be
extremely dangerous altitude sickness
can cause fluid to build up in the lungs
and brain but some tourists even spend
several nights in the hut hoping to
finish the climb the mayor of song
survey says that's a mistake mo blood of
new and Podrick blown has become a
consumer item people come to moan blown
the way they go to the movies or take a
walk in the park en cosas más abajo Mon
blown has become something banal a
product sold in travel agencies it's all
about the money and so we end up with
these problems good ol net was a problem
he wants to limit the number of tourists
allowed on the mountain and require them
to be accompanied by an experienced
mountain guide but most everyone else in
the valley rejects the idea of stricter
rules even the head of mountain rescue
is opposed
low blow Mangla is a legend people come
here from all over the world to make the
climb go more toward you or should we
tell them that we're going to build a
cable railway to the top you are boom
and then we'd see a lot fewer tourists
here Naomi and Andrew finally decide to
head back down the mountain they're
disappointed they didn't make it that's
a Hut if we were very cold you know and
you talk to other guides and everybody
in vain it's crazy to continue wind is
so strong and the ridge is so steep that
you wouldn't come back through all the
mountains with flying probably about
minus 52 minus 8 we're not is not a
climate eyes to that um yeah very
Australian yeah latest along with some
others managed to stick out the night at
the Alpine hut the next day some of the
climbers make it to the top of Mont
Blanc later they'll boast of their
experience and draw even more tourists
to venture the dangerous climb
you